el presidente de perú pedro castillo se
distanció del partido oficialista pero
libre al recomponer su gobierno sin los
ministros más allegados al polémico
líder de esta formación él es vladimir
cerrón y también reforzó el ala más
moderada del gabinete entre los siete
ministros que dejaron el cargo se
destaca el primer ministro guido bellido
que fue reemplazado por mirtha vásquez
expresidenta al congreso durante el
periodo de transición tras la crisis de
política de noviembre de 2020 bellido
tenía una investigación por presunta
apología al terrorismo y ahora quiero
saludar entonces a nuestro primer
invitado del día eres rodrigo murillo
novelista e historiador y también
analista político peruano rodrigo
gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa los saludo muy buen día
a dos meses del gobierno de pedro
castillo era necesario un cambio de este
tipo en su gabinete
buenos dias raúl un placer acompañarle
bueno estábamos asistiendo perplejos a
casi la completa parálisis de las
fuerzas fundamentales
no debemos olvidar que pedro castillo
fue incapaz de haber elaborado un
gabinete ministerial
homogéneo habían diversas fuerzas al
interior del gabinete que pugnaban por
obtener el favor presidencial y así
tenían completamente paralizada su
gestión
ahora rodrigo le pregunto por qué
siempre vemos tanta inestabilidad
política en el perú qué pasa con la
política peruana
raúl es una pregunta interesante y diría
que es casi una casualidad mire algo
positivo como la investigación profunda
en torno al caso odebrecht acabo con
algunas cabezas muy visibles de partidos
políticos en un acto que teóricamente
debería pues haber contribuido a limpiar
la política peruana de esta suerte de
corrupción crónica que la acompañaba lo
que no se pudo creer fue que cuando
desaparecieron estas cabezas visibles el
espacio podía ser tomado por otros
líderes que no solamente podrían
resultar improvisados sino partidarios
de ideologías retrógradas y capaces de
generar un inmenso cambio en el país
ahora le pregunto a rodrigo qué pasará
con la durabilidad del gobierno de
castillo si va a llegar más allá de
diciembre como muchos en perú lo decían
que este gobierno llegaba hasta
diciembre estos cambios lo pudieron
haber ayudado a tener
gobierno pues más largo o incluso
terminará su mandato y no pues como
hemos visto estos últimos meses con un
cambio de presidente pues seguido
es probable que sí y ahora hay que ver
si es que las fuerzas de castillo y el
mismo pedro castillo renuncia a su
medida política fundamental que no es
compartida por las grandes mayorías del
país que es la propuesta de la asamblea
constituyente para refundar al país la
gente según las últimas encuestas no la
quieren o la piden está más bien
enfocada en la reactivación económica la
superación de la crisis que ha generado
la pandemia y también los partidos
políticos representados en el congreso
salvo una cuota pequeña de partidos de
izquierda tampoco la piel entonces un
poco la clave está de si este nuevo
gabinete en ver si es que este nuevo
gabinete perseguirá también este
objetivo con lo cual la gobernabilidad
del país no estará garantizado y con
ello tampoco pues la permanencia del
presidente castillo en el poder ahora
rodrigo también le quiero preguntar cuál
es la percepción entre el común de los
peruanos ante estos cambios políticos si
se ve como una mayor estabilidad digamos
hablando de la sociedad peruana en la
base de la sociedad
no mira me temo decir que el liderazgo
que ejerció el anterior premier guido
venido fue nefasto para el país y
fundamentalmente para su economía el
perú ha vivido un proceso de
descapitalización histórica en que se
calcula que aproximadamente entre 16.000
y 18.000 millones de dólares han salido
del país el tipo de cambio ha subido en
consecuencia y tenemos un panorama de
incertidumbre a nivel de las inversiones
que tienen que hacerse para que la
reactivación económica pues continúe y
la gente en la calle viendo a este
primer ministro con su estilo
confrontacionista siempre en contra del
empresariado digamos reivindicando un
estilo de hacer políticas muy muy de evo
morales la gente también diría yo aún
sufría esta parálisis y estaba
expectante ante los cambios que creo yo
la mayoría demandaban presidente
castillo ahora rodrigo yo le quiero
preguntar algo con esta instancia miento
de pedro castillo pues un poco del
partido gobernante pero libre pues lo
ayuda a tener mejor imagen en el pueblo
peruano
yo creo que sí porque demuestra el
presidente castillo que es un político
que también por primera vez y creo que
para su sorpresa llegó al poder es capaz
de negociar ahora no debemos olvidar
también estamos nuevamente ante un
personaje
radicalizado extremista con algunas
convicciones izquierdistas muy profundas
que creo yo en el proceso de aprendizaje
propio que él seguirá en la presidencia
se dará cuenta ahí mismo que ya no
pueden llevarse a cabo en el contexto
actual del perú en ese contexto pues
creo que sí puede haber una mayor
aprobación siempre y cuando el
presidente castillo demuestre que la
prioridad es el bienestar del país y no
posibles lealtades ideológicas y ahora
también rodrigo dentro del congreso
porque recordemos que el congreso
peruano es de mayoría opositora al
partido pero libre como está entonces
pues el juego de poderes dentro del
congreso si es verdad que es opositor
pero también a esa oposición hay una
parte que puede apoyar al presidente
castillo para que pueda gobernar sin
tanta oposición
pues es interesante y de cierta forma un
icono el partido que era oficialista
hasta ayer es decir digamos que
representaba al oficialismo en el
congreso pero libre ha perdido numerosos
votos porque este sector recalcitrante
marxista leninista ha acusado de traidor
a pedro castillo y ha dado a entender
que no van a votar para que se le dé la
confianza a su gabinete en 30 días habrá
que ver si las restantes bancadas de
derecha y de centroderecha algunas están
dispuestas a conversar con estos nuevos
ministros pero yo creo que lo
fundamental es que haya una suerte de
acuerdo sobre lo que no es negociable en
este contexto por ejemplo la asamblea
constituyente mientras que pedro
castillo continúe
planteando esta propuesta que ni la
población ni los principales partidos
políticos comparten pues no tendrá
difícil incluso con nuestro con estos
nuevos ministros el llegar a acuerdos
rodrigo muy rápidamente 30 segundos
hacia dónde va pero que podemos ver en
las próx semanas o antes de finalizar el
año por ejemplo veremos un periodo de
negociación y veremos finalmente si
pedro castillo decide mantener su
gobierno con un rumbo basado en
consensos o si por el contrario opta por
la radicalización y probablemente por la
pérdida de su mandato